hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome to the dream smartphone 2014
video so obviously the perfect
smartphone doesn't really exist there's
always little flaws to what would
otherwise be a perfect buy so if you
could piece together different parts
from other smartphones into a
Frankenstein beast of a phone that's the
concept what would you pick I would
start off with the body of the HTC One
m8 I'll take those front-facing speakers
too while we're at it obviously nothing
beats boom sound right now
unfortunately the ma still is a little
bit slippery so I would score off the
edges a bit kind of like the Galaxy Note
4 and I take the finish from the Nokia
Lumia series so that's soft touch
instead of a raw metal soft touch is
obviously easier to hold and it's still
built like an absolute tank so for the
screen that was pretty easy for me I'm
going to go with the LG g3 5.5 inch quad
HD display thin out those side bezels a
bit tighten up the top bezels newest
speakers and we're golden 5.5 inch
display might seem a little big for some
people but screen size is not phone size
and with these tighter bezels next to
the speakers and a soft touch finish I
think this is a phone that would feel
pretty awesome in the hand so inside we
got to have top-notch specs so here in
late 2014 that means the quad-core
Snapdragon 805 3 gigs of ram the audrina
420 GPU basically the whole deal so for
the battery motor roll has been killing
it lately and I talked about this in the
last dream phone video about how they do
battery really well phones have been
getting so much thinner lately at the
expense of a battery size and I'm not a
big fan of that trend and you see the
Droid turbo is come out recently it's
not a very big phone but it has a 3900
milliamp hour battery which is awesome
so in a dream phone I'd be ok with
anything 3,500 milliamp hours or better
which would hopefully translate to 6
hours of screen on time
so for the camera I would pick the
iPhone six-plus camera because it's
awesome and basically every way it takes
awesome photos and it has optical image
stabilization but it's only 8 megapixels
which means it's not capable of shooting
4k video and I gotta have my 4k video so
I'll go with the Samsung Galaxy Note 4
is camera the best they've ever used
it's a 16 megapixel sensor it has
optical image stabilization and it does
take 4k video it's the same sensor
they've used in the galaxy s5 and
honestly I would really take any of a
number of Sony sensors they're all great
where I will still take the image
processing from the iPhone 6 just to
take the edge off the super sharpen
super saturated look from the Samsung
cameras listen I did continue for the
operating system I will still take pure
stock Android 5.0 this time lollipop and
I would take it basically stock they've
adopted a bunch of other features we've
seen on other earlier skin version of
Android but they kept that pure smooth
performance and feel so other than that
if you couldn't really tell I am NOT a
huge bells and whistles type of person I
don't need any sort of crazy swiveling
camera or heartrate monitor or ring
flash or anything like that but if it's
in the phone it better work otherwise
it's just taking up space and with 128
gigs of flash storage I think I'd be set
I wouldn't need any expansion outside of
that and that's it that's a phone that I
would be comfortable using daily for the
next two years
hey what is up guys again and slate I
usually don't do these but this is a bit
of a special video which was produced in
collaboration with the awesome video
team over at the verge you have an
awesome video production team and they
also made all the badass animations that
you saw in this video if you want to see
more awesome stuff like that then you
can check out the Virg channel which if
you haven't already seen it I'll link it
right there they do all sorts of other
animation stuff but also tech videos of
their own if you're down we'll work
together on other stuff like this so if
you have any ideas so for you to let us
know in the comment section below what
we should tackle next either way that's
been it thank you for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the next one peace